tee
[music]
necessary weiner
[applause]
But you
don't have to be like that Hey, I'm exhausted, but if the hurdles are too high, it's not going to be a good match.
The
first factor
is your subordinate, isn't it? There's no
problem
if you're the target of strength.
I
wonder what kind of magic you're going to fight with,
hmmm, you guys seem to be full of motivation, but
you guys Clover's goal is also this dungeon's treasure house.
Let's compete without it Let's do that Let's
do that
See you meow
[music]
You guys Clover people know what's happening
Our country is also struggling with resources and joblessness There
's no choice but to live, isn't it?
I'm going to
cry uncle
[music]